dans quarante ans de france de quarante
ans de carrière de michel drucker
on va faire un petit retour en arrière
on va se retrouver au temps où où tu
cherchais du boulot michel autant de la
rtf
on va vers une interview aurait été
alors à leur écoute écoute ça peut pas
mieux tomber
mais ce que je t'ai à mener pour mes 40
ans de telle est ma première apparition
à la télé ah ouais je sais pas s'ils
cherchent qu'à le fonds peut cadrer ce
serait bien qu'il y est c'est à l'image
que tu me poses disant voilà la tronche
que j'avais eu ma première apparition
alors il est à gauche et françois jannin
reporter françois jannin oui je me
souviens
et voilà l'aja on dirait jean pierre
coffe est là et là c'était il ya
quarante ans jour pour les faire jouer
bien ou mal de photos vers l'autre photo
michel tout de suite
ouais bon serge cals phone call phones
par lefa board a je sais ce que c'est il
ya trente ans je faisais déjà une
émission qui s'appelait rendez vous du
dimanche françoise côtier avec les
migrants bas qui en avait une scripte
charmant qui s'appelait catherine barma
ah oui alors inconnu script lua
catherine de voici voici françoise
coquet un assistant n'ont autant et
revoilà montant cayla et à côté de mon
temps regarder catherine barma lui
d'ivoire qui lui
catherine barma la fille de claude barma
qui on doit quelques unes des plus
belles pages de la télévision de service
public dont les rois de la grotte de
lascaux michel où il ya des
éliminatoires donc j'avais dirigé j'ai
20 ans tu as tu as 20 ans oui
aujourd'hui je reçois un jeune qui
aimerait bien faire de la faire de la
télé bonjour mon petit tu t'appelles
comment je m'appelle michel drucker
monsieur drucker ça marchera jamais ça
même michel sais pas d'où ça marchera
jamais non tu veux pas trouver un nom là
j'aurais bien peu et thierry rolland
roger couderc mais c'était déjà pris
alors tu veux faire la télé oui pourquoi
parce que je sais rien faire d'autre
pour l'instant je n'ai pas de diplôme il
paraît qu'à la télévision ils n'ont pas
dit comme je sais que ça gagne pas
beaucoup d'argent la télé michel
oui mais pour l'instant j'habite place
clichy avec ma mère juste en face chez
monsieur zitrone j'ai pas gros besoins
je prends le 80 tu as quoi comme
expérience
j'ai fait des petits boulots j'ai été
moniteur d'enfants difficiles j'étais
photographe de plage et j'ai été homme
de ménage à orly et je veux surtout pas
retourner affronter le tribunal de la
famille qui n'a toujours qui m'a
toujours pas pardonné pas avoir fait
d'études
ouais mais on va voir oui tu te verrais
bien dans quel domaine le sport car je
suis un fondu de ça le divertissement ça
te dirait oui mais albert raisner ya guy
lux i am et mortimer
il ya des gens des autres est costaud il
ya jean nohain donc en pleine bourre
jean nohain en ce moment oui mes
raisonnements oui tu aimerais présenter
des variétés un jour michel bassi un
jour on me le demande je sais qu'il ya
une dame qui m'a qui que j'aimerais
rencontrer qu' une grande productrice
elle a débloqué michel arnaud michard
nommé je la connais très bien je peux te
présenter c'est la productrice de gens
qui sont avertis elle était en plus elle
a le bras long puisqu'elle a été la
maîtresse devant un mitterrand
bah oui et elle a eu comme pianiste
serge gainsbourg j'aimerais bien la
rencontre et granby tout ça ça peut
s'arranger thème les vedettes mon petit
michel
j'aime les vedettes du sport j'aime
jacques anquetil j'aime fausto coppi et
j'aime par dessus tout raymond kopa et
just fontaine est ce que tu sais que les
vedettes faut être gentil avec elle pour
qu'elle revienne régulièrement dans des
émissions tu as bien compris ça une
chaîne subit on m'a appris est gentil à
la maison et à remercier beaucoup je
deviens ce côté provoc un peu destroy
de mon jeune frère casse mais reina dis
moi tu sais d'aidé faute à quoi comme
des faux mon chien je sais pas dire non
ouais je suis venu dépanner de mary bale
je suis très impatient et j'ai du mal à
me concentrer c'est pour ça que j'ai pas
fait d'études et puis j'ai un gros
défaut c'est que c'est que je je demande
à tous les jours à ma famille qu'est ce
que je ferai demain
ouais je suis obsédée par parfait pas
michel t'en fais pas on va peut-être
sauver quelque chose pour toi je
voudrais absolument réussir quelque part
calme toi tu as l'air très inquiet toi
j'ai juste très inquiet ah oui je suis
très inquiet d'ailleurs durant que vous
ne savez pas quel mais combien vous
dites la vérité puisque j'ai 20 ans et
déjà un début du le cera d'estomac j'ai
fait un zona ya trois mois ah oui oui
non mais faut que ça s'arrête
est-ce que tu fus monter une chaîne non
tu fume pas non tu de drogue
tu aimerais bien le drogué non j'ai
maintenant de drogués monsieur c'est
quoi ça où il va prendre la température
s'il en est fou c'est normal
bon j'imagine le gars qui zappe qui
tombent si tant est qu'ils me voient
comme ça maintenant on est obligé de
faire mal que test pour les gens qui est
aussi ça s'est produit trop basse et un
petit contrôle jacques oui c'est bien de
venir commencent ils à juba avec jacques
même s'il n'a pas vu ça va changer de
couleur
alors laurent c'est tout à fait normal
là je regarde le résultat il n'ya pas
bout et bourré très bourg et toi ces
greffes de foie
c'est très fiable du matin dans cinq ans
après avoir fait la télévision je n'en
mets j'espère justement rester plus de
cinq ans arrêt si je peux rentrer à des
visions je voudrais rester très
longtemps et tu te vois ou dans 40 ans à
la télévision
ah ouais tu crois vraiment qu'il faut
encore de la télé mais j'ai là rien je
serai bien puisque 1 mais il donne à
notre division léon zitrone chapatte
couderc et les autres ils ont 50 ans ou
méchant d'avoir 50 ans vrai à la tête à
une tête de gendre idéal entre l'a déjà
dit non j'ai une tête de gendre idéal
je sais pas c'est vrai si si si tu crois
aussi si moi je trouve que ça peut
simplement avec les filles ça marche
moyen mais il paraît que à la télévision
quand on se fait connaissent ça marche
mieux à et tu vas voir ta piège à filles
immigrantes qui a demain dans ton
émission mon petit michel ségolène royal
présidente de région poitou charentes
même de les secousses et les accompagne
la campagne françois norfendre et avec
véronique sanson il en perd est
d'imaginer un petit scoop si je ne
savais pas qu'elle avait pratiqué le
piano donc elle est beaucoup parler non
mais quelle zhu est à dire l accompagne
vers une licence mais tout le monde le
sait ah bon et manque pas de charme elle
est pas mal
la fesci dre michèle elle est nue elle
son mari non et bien son mari quand on
le connaît pas alors on n'imagine pas
que c'est un type extrêmement touchant
le connais en
voilà
bien vu
j'enfonce lésions de bronze
animé par us
jean luc delarue